si se lo canto de Blasio go go pres de
cuenta de Cuba list wa la pieza de me
Guam a mobo me agua de marchi a a
pabellón de todo Seaguar ma métropolitain
les certaines sources que je connais pour le destin
Edessa Percy McConnell faucille Minerve une
mousse polyvalente un hargneux  Burkhardt de travail
Pelton moon connu sous le nom de menu
Porfiry seguro de la Bonavena vision
photo SD glass sudo su carro CNO cuvée
trivia pas de téléphone bonjour et Levi Nami qui
n'est pas
bon bonbon vraiment
mr.  traité chocolat Abajo défaut matri
pitri un continuum est un même clivage ou
pourquoi vous Jim a Bali
ahsoka Virginia Bar bavardage ninhydrine
Samiha guerre L'Amérique sait whoa ah où
avons-nous génial Oh
oui la vente de cuticules vous savez capable de se
battre par vous-même est le quoi -  pour votre
supposition
oui monsieur avez-vous joué Joe super baisé
jamais dose a être notre Yost au moins quoi
ouais Priscilla m'a bloqué
si c'est la queue blanche comme neige que vous
cherchez découvrez l'histoire qui a
précédé le miroir miroir sur le mur qui est
la plus belle de la lune tu es ma reine
mais pas pour longtemps
ta sœur tient un bébé qui
deviendra plus beau que toi mais méfie-
toi si l'enfant est blessé ta
sœur Alicia a le pouvoir d'échapper à tout ce que le
monde a jamais connu
douleur de sa perte, la bonne
reine a construit une forteresse de glace autour de son
cœur si elle ne pouvait pas élever un enfant, elle
lèverait une armée tu t'entraîneras il
est devenu mon chasseur
ils sont sûrs que je pensais que je t'avais rendu fort
mais tu es aussi p  athétique comme tu l'as jamais
été c'est mon royaume as-tu dit quelque chose
avec la magie des miroirs je gouvernerai le
monde qui compte une chose diabolique et dangereuse
nous devons détruire
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire être le héros qui
vainc le miroir et la sécurité tout le
royaume
Je prie beaucoup,
êtes-vous prêt, cher Smith, je suis plus fort
que vous tous, allons-nous découvrir l'
histoire avant que la neige ne vous blanchisse